[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing dumbledore and the mirror of
erased the mirror of erised is a magical
mirror and hogwarts artifact located in
the room of requirement inside the
castle walls in the philosopher's stone
harry first discovers the mirror for
himself it was a magnificent mirror as
high as the ceiling with an ornate gold
frame standing on two clawed feet there
was an inscription carved around the top
erased straw eru oyt ub kafru
on wassi
then he experienced the following he
looked in the mirror again a woman
standing right behind his reflection was
smiling at him and waving he reached at
her hand and felt the air behind him if
she was really there he'd touch her
their reflections were so close together
but he only felt air she and the others
existed only in the mirror mum he
whispered dad
they just looked at him smiling and
slowly harry looked into the faces of
the other people in the mirror and saw
other pairs of green eyes like his other
noses like his even a little old man who
looked as though he had harry's knobbly
knees harry was looking at his family
for the first time in his life
after losing himself in the mirror for
hours captivated from what he was
witnessing dumbledore stumbles upon
harry in the room
so back again harry said dumbledore
slipping off the desk to sit on the
floor with him you like hundreds before
you have discovered the delights of the
mirror of erised it shows us nothing
more or less than the deepest most
desperate desires of our hearts
harry then proceeds to ask dumbledore
what do you see when you look in the
mirror to which dumbledore replies i see
myself holding a pair of thick woolen
socks one can never have enough socks he
continues so what i want to discuss in
today's video is whether or not
dumbledore was lying about this answer
many believe that dumbledore giving
harry this answer was simply a
distraction tactic a way of potentially
dissuading harry from seeking further
use of the mirror while simultaneously
avoiding harry's question maybe
dumbledore didn't want to reveal what he
really saw but dumbledore is a wise and
calculated man and so many things that
he said over the course of the books and
films have later turned out to have
profound meaning
so what's the deal with the socks
in fantastic beasts it's later revealed
that at least at a younger age
dumbledore saw grindelwald but i don't
think that answer holds true for older
dumbledore i think he did see socks
here's why dumbledore for most of his
childhood had a broken home his dad was
sent to azkaban his mother kendra died
tensions with his brother were high and
his sister was perhaps killed by a spell
sent from dumbledore's own wand this
we'll have to look at properly in
another video but that doesn't mean that
there wasn't a point which his family
did all live together under one roof one
happy family that was able to share
christmases with each other in an
interview jk rowling was once asked what
dumbledore really saw to which he
responded he saw his family alive whole
and happy aryana percival and kendra all
returned to him and aberforth reconciled
to him what this tells me is that
dumbledore's response to harry of socks
wasn't an outright lie but just one
aspect of the truth after mentioning
socks to harry he says the following
another christmas has come and gone and
i didn't get a pair people insist on
giving me books the socks that
dumbledore mentions are symbolic and
that they are representative of a warmer
time in his life homemade socks and
jumpers are almost synonymous with
family in the harry potter story and the
weasleys are a testament to that a happy
christmas full of gift giving and food
sharing dumbledore simply longed for one
thing
family and that's it for this video if
you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember happiness can be
found even in the darkest of times if
one only remembers to turn on the light
[Music]